- No. No! No no no no...
- Yeah, this is going to be horrible.
(upbeat music)
- [Man and Blonde Woman] Melon!
- Let's go.
- Okay.
Oh, God.
- Yeah, wasn't expecting this.
I'm gonna be drunk.
- I just, oh my God.
(clears throat)
- That's one of the worst
things I've ever tasted.
- God, I did not think it
was gonna be this strong.
- I would say 100% vodka, 0% melon.
- [Brunette Woman] Mmmm, cucumbers.
(cough)
I don't like it, but I don't hate it.
- When I bite it, it feels
like I'm taking a shot.
- Yeah. Except a shot that doesn't end.
- This is like if you took vodka,
and made it crunchy somehow.
- [Man] Here we go.
- [Blonde Woman] Berries!
- The color of the strawberries
is very, very scary.
- It's like, pink.
- It's like, ghost pink.
- It's actually not that bad.
It's maybe like, a eight.
- I was gonna say eight, too.
- I'm gonna try a blueberry now. Oh!
- The blueberry is completely fine.
- If you have children and
you want them to fall asleep,
get a bunch of blueberries.
- Don't do that.
- I'm getting drunk.
(laughter)
- [Man] Tomato.
- I think this is gonna
maybe taste like pizza.
- Wow.
- Like a, like you
dumped a bottle of vodka
on a pizza.
- I actually am surprised
at how not bad this is.
- Oh my God.
- It got better.
- It got worse for me!
- The alcohol is not
as strong, in this one.
- Four, this is a four out of 10.
- Seven. It was a seven for me.
- [Blonde Woman] App-
- [Brunette Woman] Are those apples?
- Wow, these apples
- These apples look gross.
- they do not look appealing.
- Smells like somebody tried
to make an apple dog food.
- Oh, this is a lot better.
Still bad.
- Oh no.
- Oh, my God.
- Much better.
- Way better.
- Much better, much more bearable.
- It's fruitier.
- I'd rather enjoy my
alcohol, as I consumed it.
- I'd rather eat food out of the garbage,
than eat this vodka food.
(upbeat music)
Why did we agree to this?
- I don't know, it sounded fun.
(creaking sign)